لا كهرباء في لبنان
محاولات اصلاحها تبقى موضوعيه في ظل نقص
التمويل
واقع يعكس ابرز اوجه الازمه الاقتصاديه
المستمره هنا والتي تسببت في تردد الخدمات
في قطاعات حيويه مثل الاتصالات والمصارف
الواضح انه من سنين لليوم القوى السياسيه
التقليديه الحاكمه لا تريد اصلاحات صندوق
النقد يتم اذا بدك تعطيل هذا الاستحقاق
واحد وراء الثاني ويتم التقادف المسؤوليات
بين القوى السياسيه نفسها الممثله في مجلس
نواب والحكومه العرقله السياسيه اذا ما قد
يودي بالبلاد حسب مسؤول صندوق النقد الى
ازمه لا نهايه لها منذ توقيعه الاتفاق
المبدئي مع صندوق النقد الدولي قبل اكثر
من عام التزم لبنان ببرنامج اصلاح شامل
على مستوى الماليه العامه والقطاع المصرفي
والقوانين شرطا لحصوله على حزمه مساعدات
بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات دولار التزامات بقيت
حبرا على ورق حتى الجزء اليسير الذي جرى
تنفيذه جاء منقوصا وفق صندوق النقد
فاستمرت تدهور في مختلف القطاعات
الاقتصاديه
فتعثر الاصلاح فاقم معاناه اللبنانيين لا
سيما موظفي القطاع العام الذين لجاوا الى
الشارع للمطالبه بتحسين اوضاعهم
يمتنع حكمه عن الحضور الى عمله في وزاره
الاقتصاد الا مره واحده كل اسبوعين لازم
توصل لصندوق النقد الدولي للمعلومات قال
له نحن عم نقبض معاش 100 دولار او 150
دولار على 4500 ليره لبناني دولارنا
الموظفين عم ندفع كل شيء بالسوق على 100
الف وعالميه لكن الاتي على هؤلاء قد
يكونوا اسوا وفق الخبراء لا سيما مع
استمرار المؤشرات الماليه في التراجع عدم
تنفيذ هذه الاصلاحات من قبل لبنان ستؤدي
الى
تدهور الوضع الاقتصادي اكثر واكثر سوف
نشهد مزيد من استنزاف الاحتياطات في مصر
في لبنان وبينما قدرت الحكومه الفجوه
الماليه باكثر من 70 مليار دولار يقول
الخبراء ان المليارات ثلاثه الموعوده من
صندوق النقد الدولي لن تشكل بحد ذاتها
وصفه التعافي الاقتصادي المنشود لكن توقيع
على اتفاق معه قد يعيد ثقه المجتمع الدولي
ب ويفتح الباب امام المساعدات والتمويل من
الجهات المانحه كاترين حنا الجزيره بيروت